alors vous faire une interview première
fois vous êtes prêts on embauche par la
géniale
oui
je sais que ça je vous dis et qu'il
avait bougé de factiva je sais pas je
sais plus il n'a fait que bouger je
regardais les autres soeurs qu'est ce
qu'il a fait il a bougé ou quoi qu'est
ce que tu en penses propre bien fort
comme dit d'interview voilà comme dit
l'interview alors premier souvenir
comment même parent la mère m'a enfermé
dans un placard elle m'a oublié je ne me
mêle chansons via pas première bêtise
juste avant j nazisme j'en connais et
l'autre à l'âge de trois ans 6,35 à tes
rides
avant j'avais tiré l'alarmé il y avait
une arme à la maison sale inquiété lors
du chauffeur de votre père larmes les
chauffeurs de mon père j'ai pris un
petit 6 35 chargé et je suis arrivé il y
avait des invités les effets haut les
mains et tout le monde a le schéma
première aventure avec un garçon ça je
vous dis enfin aventure aventure touche
pipi quoi il ya peu il ya eu une période
où j'étais tout le temps de mettre tout
nu avec des petits garçons je sais pas
si vous avez fait ça enfin les bien sûr
j'ai fait ça 1 et voilà et donc vers un
pick up
huit terrains et c'était oui c'était ce
qui m'étonne c'est que ça se passait
très très rapidement grèce est très très
vatican quoi premier baiser
on voit en provence et ab j'étais un peu
petit et gtc est monté sur un tronc
d'arbre et ça avait pris des heures à
peu près six heures pour embrasser la
loi c'est ça vous êtes très vieux après
pour chaque commande 6 heures les jeunes
vieux jeu moyen ça a beaucoup plus vite
première expérience sexuelle en
l'attention j'ai aussi la réponse je
vois tout à fait où ses terres et qui 16
ans ouais c'est ça c'est un copain
pendant l'été jean marc s'appelait
comment véronique bravo
c'est là qu'il a ressorti son 6,35 et
des chars des couleurs par tous
c'est parce que c'est bon j'ai jamais eu
ça près mais bon alors une partie carrée
ah oui bon père de 18 ans 19 ans il vous
me direz vous avez des partis car est
aussi oui je gêne pas pourquoi ouvrir un
coffre à votre charge et les parties car
elle marino de quoi et des couilles
sensas
comme un accord très bon disque savalas
format au fait vous êtes en forme
physiquement musicalement ça se passe
bien c'est mon vieil panne loin